Brutes Feldman from the athletic and Fox
Sports college football analyst right
here on the Rich Eisen show how are you
Bruce I'm doing well rich good to be out
yeah I'm good to be on with you two here
before we get to the four let's talk
about who's not in it what is the
college football playoff committee
telling Clemson by putting Clemson at
five in the first iteration of this
college football playoff I think they're
telling them that they know the ACC
stinks
and that the rest of the ACC is just not
very good I think they're also telling
them hey we saw you almost lose to a
really mediocre North Carolina team and
I think that is is hurt them but it's
you know in the end unless they stumble
and they have Clemson has no margin for
error some of these SEC teams a few
might have a little margin for error and
are one of them is getting way more
benefit of the doubt okay so no margin
for error meaning they can't slip up
Clemson in any way shape or form by
dropping one game in 2019 because their
conference stinks or because their
schedule wasn't nearly in there MA and
in the minds of the college football
playoff committee up to snuff to benefit
from just one late season slip-up in
division during conference I would say
it's more of less of their conference
stinks because I'm not gonna fault
Clemson too much they scheduled two SEC
teams there are there are one of their
big rivals of South Carolina not their
fault South Carolina hasn't been very
good by the way that South Carolina team
did go to Georgia and beat the Bulldogs
right and they played Texas A&M who is
getting better and I mean that's not bad
to schedule two SEC teams in the
non-conference the problem is everybody
else is just not good in the ACC right
now the only team I think that is
playing very well is Wake Forest and
Wake Forest if they lose to Clemson
they're gonna probably be hanging around
maybe a top 25 team maybe not so that's
just not giving them much much of much
juice in the committee's eyes and when
they play a conference title game
they're probably not going to be dealing
with their tops
five teens so they're not going to get
much of a boost off that either and
that's why if they stumble somewhere I
don't think they're gonna make a play
off now I mean they're gonna stumble but
that's kind of the reality right I guess
so Bruce but why cuz what move you know
why should Clemson have to suffer
because the conference stinks when we're
looking at potentially a winner of a
pac-12 championship game between Utah
and an Oregon having a better standing
coming out of the pac-12 then a one loss
Clemson should Clemson slip up over the
next month I just think cuz the pac-12
is a little better across the board than
what you have yes he is really bad right
now we're seeing a win there's there's
basically three you know programs that I
would say fitness with a mind mode of
being powerhouse programs two of them
are way down right now
Florida State just fired Willie Taggart
after less than two seasons and Manny
Diaz in year one in Miami is very shaky
and when you look when you're second
best program right now is Wake Forest
and that's look credit to Dave closer
than that staff but they are not you
know it's it's just not they are not
seen as an elite program and so when
it's Clemson and everybody else is kind
of just spinning their wheels or feels
like a 500 team that's not going to
convince the committee of much and again
it's not like they they completely
dominated these teams they played they
really struggled against a very average
North Carolina team they almost lost
that game and that hurts I mean you keep
it's Ohio State has just pulverized
everybody they played and they've played
at least a little better competition
than what clemson has played
Bruce Feldman Fox Sports college
football analyst also from the athletic
here in the Honda inside a report where
does the committee meet walk me through
and I'll explain why in a second why I'm
asking this question what they are in
the Dallas area not that far from the
airport in this in this place that is
the Gaylord hotel that's like its own
little flash city and itself and almost
like a little dude
into itself okay and and and how many
people are there does everyone do it in
person
everyone literally flies in every I mean
yes so we've had we you know there's
been a lot of us who in the media who
have taken part in this mock exercise to
give us a little bit of a feel for what
goes on they don't give you the eat the
same year I don't remember I made this
five years earlier the model that my
group had to do and you simulate you're
one of the people who is who is who is
uh you know at that point I think I was
supposed to be Tyrone Willingham okay so
he was on the committee at that point
and so you kind of you're recused from
certain things if you have certain kind
of connections and you have to leave the
room or you're not part of that
discussion so you so the media has gone
through like a simulator sort of like
you know because they I mean I just saw
Apollo 13 so like you're the like you go
through like a simulator like you're in
the the football LEM and you walk
through this so you have a better
understanding of what the college
football committee is going through you
do what the thing is rich everybody
brings their own biases to this and the
get-out-of-jail-free card for them is
who do we think who do I think is best
where's this I test fits and that's why
I think you see Alabama in the top in
the top four when Alabama hasn't played
anybody either
relative to what Clemson scheduled well
the reason we played anybody know the
reason why I'm asking all this Bruce is
I'm just wondering if the Security's
tight there or who's who is monitoring
the food or the drink because somebody
must have dropped something in there
with LSU and Alabama playing a game that
the whole country is gonna stop for and
it's the SEC and it just wait a minute
let me look at my notes here means more
and a Big Ten team was was ranked higher
than every other team did that that
really just happened I mean a Big Ten
team is better than an SEC team really
just like that Bruce I mean it's now
it's not a one two at the two three I
don't think it's gonna diminish any of
the buzz around it it just maybe CB
probably probably kind of wince when
they saw that whatever it was at 9:30
Eastern or whatever that thing rolled
around one up there huh you can't they
can't put a one-day that belongs to a
Big Ten team from Columbus how about
that yeah look
well because of Notre Dame they can't
put it at night either because they put
their money on the Notre Dame Georgia
game and I'm sure you know that rated
well this thing I'm sure will will
little rake gangbusters and look at a
lot of this is gonna shake out if LSU
beats Alabama in Tuscaloosa I'd be
surprised if LSU is not going to be the
number one team in the in the playoff
rankings and then a lot of this stuff
doesn't matter that much at this point
no I really gets overblown because
everybody does play each other and well
you know what we will see eventually a
conversation about who makes it and and
and then there will be some really angry
people but I'll remove my tongue firmly
planted in cheek for a second to say why
is Ohio State ranked part of me the Ohio
State ranked above two SEC teams through
a couple months here in your estimation
the eyeball test has helped them they
have been dominant on both sides of the
ball as somebody who has seen Ohio State
in person this year I would agree with
that there's been the most impressive
team and I feel like it's talented as
Ohio State has been in the last few
years and and you see a lot of that
reflected on all those guys were in the
NFL now and doing well I think this team
feels different than the ones that are
benaiah had in the last few years and
just the way they are playing and their
strength to schedule the numbers
actually are pretty good now certainly
in Wisconsin as as sputtered a little
bit but you see I think they're going to
get a boost off that there's something
going to get a boost off of when they
play Penn State they're gonna get a
boost off a plane your alma mater I
don't you know the way the committee has
done this they may have an opportunity
to be a a 12 and one conference champ
and get into the playoff it would not
shock me right now not saying it's a
lock
but you may have as much chance of two
Big Ten teams getting in as you have
potentially of two
SEC teams getting in I mean we'll see
what happens now but I think Penn State
has got the committee's attention
they're gonna play Minnesota who hasn't
really played anybody yet but they are
undefeated Penn State whips them they're
gonna play an Indiana team that you know
hasn't really played anybody great yet
either but they're seven and two I mean
Penn State as real as a lot of has a lot
that they can build off of from momentum
and certainly Ohio State does - what if
Minnesota runs a table sir that would
mean that they would have wins against
Penn State and Wisconsin and Iowa and
assumedly against the Ohio State in
Indianapolis in a Big Ten championship
game there's a path there just the same
as there's a path for Baylor - wouldn't
you say right now oh there's definitely
a path I mean they those teams and
certainly I would put Baylor in this
they they just aren't gonna get the
benefit of the doubt some of these other
powerhouse programs are gonna get right
now and especially would with
Minnesota's non-conference thing and
what it was I mean our crew happened to
do the their first game they played FCS
South Dakota State and they had their
hands full with them they're you know
give them credit they are undefeated
eight but they have played a bunch of
teams that I've had backup quarterbacks
when they've had to play them and so I
think that there is still a lot of
skepticism with Minnesota that's why you
don't see them in the top 16 you see
them behind a two loss Michigan you see
them behind two loss Florida and Auburn
and even k-state so but they are they
now is where it gets heavy and if they
if they can answer the bell on these and
beat some of these better teams they're
gonna they're gonna shoot up the shoot
up the committee rankings but right now
I think there's there's still quite a
bit of skepticism with them and and you
know similar to similar to where I think
Baylor is at right now I mean they're
not as far back within third they're 12
but they are behind a couple of two loss
teams from the SEC as well and in terms
of one-loss teams Georgia Oregon Utah
and Oklahoma you see this week who has
the best chance to win out and make it
you think
Georgia I'm sorry Georgia Georgia and
Oklahoma who you see this week yeah I
don't think you know George is gonna
have to get through either LSU or Auburn
it looks like and I I mean that to me
that's a much tougher opponent than
either of than anybody else is gonna
have there I would say Oklahoma to me
has the best chance because I think
they're the best team in the big 12
whereas Utah and Oregon are very similar
so Oregon has the better offensive line
Utah has the better defensive line as
Utah's quarterback is playing terrific
Tyler Huntley but he is playing on a
gimpy knee if he gets help if he can get
healthy or I think that will help them
but and look Utah the rest of their
regular season schedule they're gonna
play three teams that are all sub 500 so
they should they should cruise into the
pac-12 title game whereas I still think
though Oklahoma to me as the class of
the big 12 especially with Lincoln
Riley's office I would say Oklahoma has
the best chance of making it through to
run the table to get to the playoff
Bruce thanks for the time man travel
safe to the heartland
enjoy I awoke Lahoma and we'll chat down
a line there's gonna be lots to talk
about
there will thank you right back at you
at Bruce Feldman cfb on Twitter I follow
him you should as well for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV
for free on BR Live or download the Rich
Eisen show app